The dating game show
where two sexual women
guess how their
relationship
with three eligible
bachelors might end.
Let's meet our
contestants.
Amy, tell us a little
bit about yourself.
Okay, um,
well, I'm a--
I'm 31 years old.
I'm from Columbus, Ohio.
And I enjoy repeating
the same mistakes
over and over again
and never growing.
Fun.
Larissa, I understand
you're from Indiana?
That's right and
romantically, I do have a type
and that's anyone who
reminds me of my dad.
Ho-ho, Papa,
can you hear me?
(laughing)
Okay, let's play.
Here's our first
bachelor.
Hi, my name's Brent.
I'm an accountant
from Atlanta.
So Amy, how do you see this
relationship ending?
Okay, uh, we'll go on
three terrible dates
and, uh, he'll make me order
appetizers as entrees
and even though I'm mildly
disgusted by him
it'll bother me that I never
hear from him again.
I could believe that.
Larissa.
Uh, I think we'd probably go
out for about two months.
And then I would discover that
he writes movie reviews
for a white
supremacist website.
Let's see what
Brent has to say.
My favorite movie
was "Lincoln."
I thought
Daniel Day-Lewis
was incredible as
that war criminal.
Perfect ending.
Larissa, you're
on the board.
Whoo!
Let's meet our
next bachelor.
Hey, my name is Ryan.
I'm from the Bronx and
I work at Fill-a-Bear.
A lot of people mishear
that as Build-a-Bear.
But Fill-a-Bear
is different.
See I empty out
old Teddy Bears
and then I sell the
carcasses to Build-a-Bear.
Larissa.
Well, first of all, I will
fall in love with Brent
because he looks
like my dad,
uh, which will
cause me to turn
into a hoarder
like my mother...
Ten seconds Larissa.
Oh, uh, and then, uh, we'll
have a huge fight one day
when he throws out
one of my treasures,
an umbrella that
says Advil on it
and then he walks out
of my life forever
and I call my dad...
(buzzer)
Amy.
Okay, after dating
for about six months
I accidentally
get pregnant
and even though we're not
really together anymore
he won't let me
get an abortion?
(bell dinging)
Good answer.
Well, let's see what
Ryan has to say.
I would never pay
child support.
But I'm strongly
pro-life.
Don't argue with me
'cause I'm not smart enough
to defend my position.
Yankees rule.
Amy, you nailed it.
Nice.
Let's check out our
final bachelor.
I work at the
Apple Genius Bar.
Amy, how do you
see this ending?
Okay, um, I think I've
got this one, Tom.
We'll date for
about eight months
and then I'll open
a folder on his desktop
labeled
football stuff
and find 400 photos
of Daniel Radcliffe.
(bell dinging)
Amy, I'm gonna stop
you right there.
You're absolutely right.
Yes, yes, yes.
It's happened a lot.
I'm gay.
Congratulations,
Amy, you win.
Nice!
Join us next week for another
episode of "How..."
Hey, dad, it's me.
Well, I lost just like
you said I would.
Yeah, I can call
you back later.